my name is
a woman from Afghanistan
before Taliban took the power I was a
prosecutor
enjoying the view of Madrid a beta
sharara and her family had their lives
turned upside down when the Taliban
returned to power in 2021 they fled
because of threats linked to her work as
a prosecutor specializing in
gender-based violence now finally
they're starting a new life in Spain
where they've got Refugee status
a bada appreciates her new freedom but
can't forget the people she's left
behind
they are sentenced to be inside their
houses inside the walls
and this is not stale I cannot enjoy
from my life because because the women
in my country they are not free they
cannot do anything
a beta was one of the 32 women judges
and prosecutors who fled Afghanistan
only to be stuck in Pakistan waiting for
Asylum many say they feel abandoned by
the outside world
one prosecutor who wanted to be known
only by her initials SM specialized in
gender-based violence and violence
against children in Afghanistan as well
as being threatened by Taliban members
and families of criminals she'd sent to
prison she was pressured by her own
relatives
even my first husband received
threatening phone calls and calls from
his family trying to convince him to
stop me because I was not a good example
for their wives who might learn the way
to fight for their rights and may put
them in prison my husband was an
open-minded person
men and women you have to stop to work
the same day in Spain a chance for some
of the 19 Afghan women prosecutors
who've been granted Asylum here to talk
with European lawyers the latter all
agree their Afghan counterparts were
held up as symbols of democratic success
only to be discarded by Western
governments they had to
fight
sometimes with members of their families
with colleagues with the cultures now
they seem to be forgotten so this is
really terrible
back in Pakistan the prosecutors are
just a tiny group on top of the millions
of Afghans who fled here after the
Soviet invasion in 1979 and during the
subsequent Civil War
for these women it's been more than a
year in limbo
but for SM there's good news her
family's on the Move heading for the
airport and a flight to Spain
the emotions clear
as they head for Europe they can only
hope they'll be able to return safely
one day Nadine barber Al Jazeera